all right so now we come to the most
important question
what is your work set up like what what
what operating uh system you use which
editor you use do you have any special
workflow which helps in your
productivity
so i sorry
that was just a lighthooded movement
it's a good question i use i used to use
linux for the last maybe 20 years but
lately i actually i don't know how i use
a mac because i like the the m1 you know
the apple m1 max they're really fast the
cpu is really really fast and so it um
to give you an example it uh i had the
latest intel
desktop machine at
leno and
it uh you know a lot of money and so on
and you know very latest and it compiled
um fortran in maybe 16 seconds and then
um
my wife's we bought this cheapest you
know
for 13 for 1 300
you know this apple and one
and it compiled as a fortran at the same
time so how's that even possible you
know like
so so this is just you have to see it to
believe it but yeah i timed it i counted
side by side even i click enter on both
you know i log into my computer network
and then
on the local terminal i hit enter at
both
so
yeah so anyway and then
so right now i have the apple and one
back that's even faster so it compiles
it in about 11 seconds for 12 seconds so
anyway so i i just like this speed so
much and ultimately and regarding the
rest i'm actually even with you i was
using ubuntu and i guess i was not
really
you know one thing i learned is that if
you start customizing the desktop too
much then you come to a new computer you
have to customize everything else so i
just kind of use the stock you want to
know customizations i use a terminal
obvious for most of my work and i have
my like dot
the dot files you know for with the
configuration but for the same reasons
like try to keep it very simple so i use
vm as my editor or new vm i guess
um
and um
and git so i have a git config file but
that's it i think those are the two main
config files lately i started also using
to use vs code which is an editor ide i
guess
um but so i use
vein and vs code and so on the mac i
still use vm and vs code and a terminal
and i don't use anything else so
for me the workflow just doesn't change
and if i use windows i would do the same
thing i would use vs code i will use a
terminal
i think windows has a like this nice new
terminal
so i would use that and i would use vein
also so i can use any operating system i
guess
okay good to know so i was using uh
wayman a bunch of open source software
on windows
and every time i had to tinker with it a
little bit i had to look up online and
all the help was from the linux guys so
actually i was putting in more effort in
windows trying to get them to work so i
thought that what the heck let me just
move over to linux it'll be easier
maintaining them and i have been doing
it so this particular recording is being
i mean i'm on ubuntu 24. so
yeah there we go